[Música]
en los 1600 la compañía holandesa de las
indias orientales empleó cientos de
barcos para comerciar oro porcelana
especias y sedas en todo el mundo pero
ejecutar esta operación masiva no era
barato con el fin de financiar sus
costosos viajes la empresa se dirigió a
los ciudadanos privados individuos que
podrían invertir dinero para financiar
el viaje a cambio de una parte de las
ganancias del buque esta práctica
permitió a la compañía realizar viajes
aún más importantes aumentando los
beneficios para ellos y sus inversores
inteligentes
vendiendo estas acciones en cafeterías y
puertos de embarque en todo el
continente la compañía holandesa de las
indias orientales inventó sin saberlo el
primer mercado de valores del mundo
desde entonces las empresas han recogido
fondos de inversores dispuestos a apoyar
todo tipo de empresas y hoy el mercado
de valores tiene escuelas carreras e
incluso canales de televisión completos
dedicados a entenderlo
pero el mercado de valores moderno es
mucho más complicado que su Encarnación
original
Cómo utilizan el mercado hoy en día las
empresas y los inversores
imaginemos una nueva compañía de café
que decide lanzarse al mercado
primero la compañía se anunciará a los
grandes inversores si piensan que la
empresa es una buena idea toman la
primera oportunidad de invertir y luego
patrocinan la oferta pública inicial de
la compañía o ipo esto lanza la empresa
en el mercado público oficial donde
cualquier empresa o individuo que crea
que el negocio podría ser rentable puede
comprar una acción comprar acciones hace
Dueños parciales del negocio a los
inversionistas su inversión ayuda a la
empresa a crecer y a medida que se
vuelve más exitosa más compradores
pueden ver el potencial y comenzar a
comprar acciones a medida que aumenta la
demanda de esas acciones también lo hace
su precio aumenta el costo para los
posibles compradores y eleva el valor de
las acciones de la empresa que las
personas ya poseen para la compañía este
aumento del interés ayuda a financiar
nuevas iniciativas y también aumenta su
valor de Mercado global mostrando cuánta
gente está dispuesta a invertir en su
idea
si por alguna razón una empresa empieza
a aparecer menos rentable lo contrario
también puede suceder si los inversores
piensan que el valor de sus acciones va
a disminuir venderán sus acciones con la
esperanza de obtener ganancias antes de
que la empresa pierda más valor conforme
las acciones se venden y su demanda
disminuye el precio de las acciones cae
y con ello el valor de Mercado de la
empresa esto puede dejar a los
inversores con grandes pérdidas A menos
que la empresa vuelva a haberse rentable
este sube y baja de oferta y demanda
está influenciado por muchos factores
las empresas están bajo la ineludible
influencia de las fuerzas del mercado
como el precio fluctuante de los
materiales cambios en la tecnología de
producción y Los costos cambiantes del
trabajo
los inversores pueden estar preocupados
por los cambios en el liderazgo mala
publicidad o factores como nuevas leyes
y políticas y por supuesto muchos
inversores están listos para vender
acciones valiosas y perseguir intereses
personales todas estas variables causan
ruido en el mercado lo que puede hacer
que las empresas parezcan más o menos
exitosas y en el mercado de valores para
hacer perder valor a menudo lleva a
perder inversionistas y a su vez perder
valor real la confianza humana en el
mercado tiene el poder de desencadenar
todo desde aujes económicos hasta crisis
financieras y esta variable difícil de
rastrear es por lo que la mayoría de los
profesionales promueven inversiones
confiables a largo plazo
sin embargo los expertos crean
constantemente herramientas y se
esfuerzan por aumentar sus posibilidades
de éxito pero el mercado de valores no
es solo para ricos y poderosos con
internet los inversionistas corrientes
pueden comprar acciones en muchas de las
mismas formas en que un gran inversor lo
haría Y a medida que más gente se educa
sobre este complejo sistema también
puede comerciar acciones apoyar a las
empresas en las que cree y perseguir sus
objetivos financieros el primer paso es
invertir
Alguien ha intentado contratarlo En una
compañía que parece un poco bueno
sospechosa no ignore las señales de
alerta ve a este video para comprender
Cómo identificar un esquema de pirámide
[Música]